this video is sponsored by the book
summary app blinkist
if right now you were told that you
would relive this life exactly how it
has gone and exactly how it will go with
all its ups and downs fortunes and
tragedies pleasures and pains over and
over for eternity
what would you think
would you be terrified would you want to
change it would you be happy with it
what could you do or think to make it
okay and perhaps even desirable
19th century philosopher friedrich
nietzsche used the version of this
contemplation as a sort of thought
experiment referred to as the eternal
recurrence in part to consider and
explore one of his important
philosophical tenets known as amurfati
the phrase amurphati is latin for love
of one's fate
this concept is recognized to have first
been referenced and discussed in the
philosophical work of stoic philosophers
epictetus and marcus aurelius however
nietzsche would be the first to
explicitly use and focus on the phrase
molding and integrating it as a unique
important value of his philosophy
he would most notably discuss the idea
in his books the gay science echo homo
as well as throughout other works notes
and letters
by this point in his life nietzsche had
retreated to the swiss alps and was
experiencing what one could easily infer
as a period of deep self-reflection over
a life that was spiked with hardships
and failures he had fled from his family
and career in academia to find
independence and pursue freelance
writing however he would not escape the
reverberating negative effects of his
family nor could he find success in his
writing he lost friendships romances and
soon to be his mind his health waned
worse and worse throughout his mid-life
as a result of various ailments and he
would frequently be bedridden and in
pain his work was essentially all he had
and it was not enough at least at the
time his books did not sell well and his
philosophy went mostly unnoticed his
life was beset with failure after
failure misery after misery until he
died a relatively horrible death of
course we now know that following
nietzsche's death he would go on to
become a massive global success rising
to prominence as arguably one of the
greatest philosophical minds to ever
live
and so how did such a brilliant
philosophical mind deal with such a
failure-ridden dreadful existence
he attempted to philosophize it to
derive wisdom and understanding from it
he concepted and integrated his view of
amur fatih
for nietzsche when referring to amor
fati he is arguably talking more
generally about the loving of one's life
the term love is also essential here as
a key nuance to his usage it suggests
more than a stoic acceptance and rather
an almost enthusiastic and total
adoration it is a sentiment or rather a
declaration against a tendency to regret
to assume one could have retained more
control over the outcomes and conditions
of their reality to have done
differently to have known any better
to have found that an existence void of
particular negatives would have
ultimately netted more positive
and instead to love and embrace all of
life exactly how it is with all the good
and the bad the success and the failure
the satisfaction and the pain
my formula for human greatness is
amurfati nietzsche writes that one wants
nothing to be different not in the
future not in the past not for all
eternity not only to endure what is
necessary still less to conceal it all
idealism is falseness in the face of
necessity
but to love it
naturally and understandably we tend to
find ourselves doing the opposite
deluded by the mirage of hindsight and
wishful thinking
it seems as though there are options to
have done differently for things to go
differently to be better we regret and
yearn for otherness
in a theoretical sense this may be true
there were potential different options
to choose from in the past and different
potential ways for things to go in the
future but in this reality the one we
must live there was no option to have
done differently and there is no other
way for things to go
every decision you've made is the best
and only decision you could have made at
the time with the information you had
and the state of mind you were in and
every condition of life that either
these decisions led to or that are
fundamental to life in general you have
no control over and cannot change
to regret or desire to go back and edit
the past assumes that the things we wish
to change presumably things we perceive
and interpret as negative are in the
bigger picture purely negative or
somehow avoidable in an equivalent sense
it assumes that one could know what is
truly and ultimately best how things
would have gone if they went differently
and that somehow one would not still
find themselves in a likely similar
state of regret and loathing if they did
it is not necessarily that life could
have been different that is the problem
but that we resist finding the beauty
and how it inevitably has gone
resenting or fighting against what has
happened to you or because of you only
brings additional misery onto the now
exasperating and adding more to resent
and resist
like pouring a gasoline of regret onto a
fire of unchangeable circumstances we
only unnecessarily intensify the flames
the true challenge and task of life for
nietzsche is to fall in love with what
you are actually experiencing right now
as it is in all the ways it is
i want to learn more and more to see as
beautiful what is necessary in things
then i shall be one of those who make
things beautiful
amurfati let that be my love henceforth
i do not want to wage war against what
is ugly i do not want to accuse i do not
even want to accuse those who accuse
looking away shall be my only negation
and all in all and on the whole someday
i wish to be only a yes sayer
nietzsche wrote
this overcoming of regret and loathing
and resistance the question posed in
nietzsche's eternal recurrence of
whether or not you would want to live
your life over whether or not you love
or could love your life is not at all
obvious or easy
in the previous quote it should be noted
that it concludes with the words someday
i wish to be
arguably nietzsche alluded to it as a
task of existence because of how
difficult and perhaps unlikely it is for
most people to say yes to perhaps the
notion of amorphati is more of an ideal
that nietzsche establishes to strive
toward
ultimately to experience the moments of
treachery and loneliness failure and
disaster loss and death and all the rest
that pervades existence and to still say
yes i love it is perhaps impossible in a
specific case by case sense but perhaps
in certain moments of high enough
spirits sufficiently distanced from
misfortune it is possible to practice a
certain love for the whole of it
and for nietzsche achieving this is the
greatest affirmation of life which can
then be used to construct the lens
through which we see the beauty in
everything and more frequently arrive at
that resounding yes
ultimately the question may not be how
much you love your life right now but
how much you could and how and perhaps
sometimes the only way to experience the
beauty of things is to think about
things in a beautiful way
throughout his career nietzsche wrote
extensively about the value of
self-overcoming achievement vitality and
power the constant defining and
accomplishment of new goals set forth in
the image of what one views as their
ideal self and yet interestingly and at
first pass almost contradictorily the
focus of amorfati offers a much gentler
and more passive sentiment
however amurphati need not deny the
notion of trying to overcome and
accomplish of trying to thrash and swim
against the current of existence and
achieve things within it or control
where it takes us
rather one's fate includes this it
includes trying to overcome life's
conditions and failing in some ultimate
sense
and arguably this idea of amorphati was
in its own right an overcoming of
nietzsche's as well as potentially for
those who adopt it an overcoming of this
ultimate conclusion of self-overcoming
the unattainable ideal self and ideal
life
amorphati is a sentiment of willingness
to accept at last the way things have
gone and will go to love a life that
tries in almost every moment to make you
hate it and to still stare back at it
and say yes i love it
what's scarier than an opponent who
smiles while being beaten
and perhaps because of that nietzsche
remains arguably one of the most notable
and dynamic philosophers of all time
[Music]
this video was sponsored by blinkist
the absurdity of regret aside one thing
many people do tend to likely wish they
had done more of by the end of their
life as engage more actively in their
personal curiosities and passions
with the book summary app blinkist you
can easily and efficiently engage in the
plethora of literature on the world and
make the decision now to do it later in
those foolish but sometimes unavoidable
moments of regret you might wish you had
done blinkist works by taking thousands
of non-fiction books and condensing them
into convenient 15-minute summaries
these summaries can be both read or
listened to even while you're offline
blinkist has over 27 categories so
whether you're interested in philosophy
psychology science finance or whatever
else blinkist has titles for just about
anyone if you're interested in learning
more about nietzsche blinkist has i am
dynamite a biography written about him
by super doe as well as beyond good and
evil and original work written by
nietzsche blinkist is perfect for those
who want to engage in books without
sacrificing too much time for heavier
readers who want to optimize their
search and discovery of new books or
readers who would benefit from more
easily returning to and refreshing
themselves on books they've already read
the first 100 people to use the link in
the description will receive one free
week of unlimited access as well as 25
off a full membership the free seven-day
trial can be canceled at any time within
the trial period
and of course as always thank you so
much for watching in general and see you
next video
you